el presidente Turco recepta y perdón ha
señalizado esta tarde una nueva
operación militar turca sobre el terreno
consolado sobre el terreno en contra de
las iepg en el norte de Siria eso se ha
dicho erdován si Dios quiere será en el
futuro próximo nada de ningún tipo de
calendario ni una certeza de que esto va
a ocurrir sin embargo sería una
continuación de la campaña aérea de
operación militar aérea que Turquía
empezó este pasado domingo en contra de
las yepegué en el noreste de Siria y el
pegaca laguer y del pegaca acá en el
norte de Irak estas dos milicias según
Turquía son las que están detrás del
atentado que ocurrió hace 10 días en el
centro de Estambul por el que murieron
seis personas tras la explosión de un
artefacto explosivo en una de las calles
más peatonales de la ciudad turca desde
que empezó la operación militar aérea
por el momento solo de Turquía este
domingo los muertos civiles han apilado
tanto a un lado de la frontera como del
otro ayer las siete que contestaron las
primeras bombardeos de Turquía con
disparos de mortero que causaron la
muerte de tres personas
ha atacado una base militar de estas
yepegué en el noreste de Siria y ha
causado la muerte de dos milicianos en
una base muy cercana a donde se
encuentran los militares estadounidenses
son los estadounidenses los que han
estado utilizando a estas y en su guerra
en contra del estado islámico Durante
los últimos años